breaking overnight in other news the
texas supreme court is blocking a lower
court order that allowed doctors to
resume performing abortions up to six
weeks into pregnancy the ruling comes as
president biden says he has only begun
the effort to protect abortion rights
following last week's supreme court
decision overturning roe versus wade
speaking on friday with governors who
are working to protect abortion access
in their states mr biden warned that the
high court could go further and take
away other rights like same-sex marriage
and contraception christina rafini is at
the white house with more christina good
morning
good morning dana abortion rights
activists are now focusing on one of the
only levers they have left and that's
the one inside the voting booth
president biden said yesterday that if
democrats lose congress in the midterms
women across the country could lose
access to abortion
this is not over it's not over in a
virtual meeting president biden told
nine democratic governors of states
where abortion is still legal they are
shouldering the burden for the nation we
either elect federal senators and
representatives who will codify roe
republicans who will elect the house and
senate will try to ban abortions
nationwide
the supreme court's overturn of almost
five decades of precedent has left women
in several states to navigate a sea of
legal uncertainty this is a frightening
time for women all across our nation a
lot of fear and anxiety out there of the
26 states that already have or are set
to ban or severely restrict abortion
judges in five including kentucky have
temporarily allowed abortions to
continue while the lawsuits play out
people were already facing difficulties
in accessing care whether it was paying
for the care
or transportation in wisconsin abortion
stopped after the state's law reverted
to an 1849 ban something its attorney
general is trying to undo and in florida
a ban sent to take effect yesterday on
abortions after 15 weeks was temporarily
blocked by a judge who said it violated
state privacy protections it was not of
course something you know that we were
happy to see in arkansas a trigger law
is now in effect banning all abortions
even in cases of rape or incest unless
they are mandatory to save the life of
the mother last year we had about 3 000
abortions in arkansas governor asa
hutchinson said that means states like
his that have outlawed the procedure
will need to step up others will go out
of state which i think will be a small
minority
but there'll be many that will carry
that child to term and to keep that
child and so we want to make sure that
we have the wraparound services
for that mom both
during the pregnancy but also afterwards
now for the first time we're hearing
president biden say he would support an
exception in the senate filibuster in
order to codify the rights and
protections of roe v wade into law the
issue is ed they probably don't have the
votes in their own party to make that
happen
that's right christina rafini on the
north line of the white house thank you